"I know the nigger.
The employer must have
some sort of punishment.
I don't care what it is,
if you'll let me tie him
down by the thumbs, or
keep him on bread and
water, that will do.
All I want is just to
have it so that when I get
the niggers onto my place,
and the work has begun,
they can't sit down and
look me square in the face
and do nothing."
Mississippi planter
to a Freedman's Bureau
official.
The language is
what the language is.
"Let me find some way or
give me some way that I
can punish these people so
they'll do the work that I
need them to do." We
can see in this quote how
politics, labor, and
free will are intertwined.
These are the
themes for this week,
this week being beginning
of the second week of
lectures, although
we're meeting on Friday.
We'll be looking at
the way politics,
and labor, and free
will are in the mix,
as it were, throughout
this particular era.
We're moving this week
from the very end of the
Civil War, 1865
to about 1877.
Well, at least
for this lecture,
excuse me, the period
known as Reconstruction.
Now when thinking
about Reconstruction,
the general attempt by
the Union or by the United
States to bring the
Union back together,
when we think
about Reconstruction,
it's really important
to understand that we're
talking about an
evolving set of ideas,
an evolving set of
political strategies.
Now I'm simplifying
things when I say it,
there's no doubt about
it, but there is a real
element of improvisation
during this era,
an experimentation
as the country,
at the federal level to
the most local level,
is trying to figure out
how to heal the wounds of
division.
I want to map out for you
the basic chronology of
this era and
then we'll be,
I'll be moving forward in
this chronology and then
working backwards
again back to 1865.
So November of 1864,
Lincoln's reelected.
By April of 1865
he's assassinated.
Before he dies, however,
and after his reelection,
he starts working on plans
to complete emancipation.
He had already made
the proclamation,
the
Emancipation Proclamation,
in 1863, but he was
concerned that after the
war there might be
attempts to see or to
interpret the Emancipation
Proclamation as merely a
wartime resolution and
not something permanent.
And for Lincoln the
die has been cast now.
He's got to find a way
to make emancipation
permanent.
And so he starts working
with Congress and other
individuals for the
passage of what would
become the Thirteenth
Amendment for the
Constitution--to
the Constitution.
The first of three
so-called Reconstruction
Amendments.
The Thirteenth Amendment
abolishes slavery.
Again, making sure
that the Emancipation
Proclamation is more than
just a wartime measure,
that it would emancipate
those people who are
legally still kept
as slaves after the
Emancipation Proclamation.
So looking
directly at this slide,
you're going to see
Lincoln's assassinated in
1865.
Excuse me. At
the end of 1865,
The Thirteenth Amendment
abolishing slavery is
passed.
You enter into
phase of Presidential
Reconstruction followed
by Radical Reconstruction.
Then you have the two
other Reconstruction
Amendments,
the Fourteenth,
establishing the
lines of citizenship and
guaranteeing due process,
the Fifteenth Amendment,
guaranteeing the right
to vote that would not be
mitigated based on
your race or previous
servitude, and by 1877,
withdrawal of Northern
troops, the end of
the Reconstruction.
I want you to get this
down in your notes so you
understand the chronology
that I'll be going back
over for the rest of
this particular lecture.
So Lincoln's reelected,
he's building a plan,
advocating a plan
that would turn into the
Thirteenth Amendment,
calling for a complete end
of slavery in
the United States.
Things aren't looking
good for the South.
It seems that the North
is going to win the Civil
War. Even before
Lincoln's assassinated,
he seems pretty certain
that's going to be the
case.
And so several
central questions,
now that the tide has
turned in this way,
simply have to
be addressed.
And these are the
questions that are really
the--I'll be spending
the lecture addressing.
And the questions might
seem kind of strange to
you, but as you'll see,
they're rather relevant to
the ways in which whites
and blacks are responding
to this new era
in US history.
"What does one do with
blacks now they've been
emancipated?
How will they
be controlled?"
I use that language
very intentionally.
"Who will do the work and
how will the South survive
the upheaval?"
What I want to do--this is
an incredibly complicated
era, and I've always been
struggling with the right
way to tell this story.
What I want to do for
the rest of the lecture is
tell the narrative mainly
from a standpoint of high
politics, electoral,
formal processes and
legislatures,
for instance,
and then I want to go back
over the same time period
looking at the
social history,
what's sort of
happening on the ground.
So it's giving
you the heads up,
we'll be looping back
over--going back to 1865
and starting
over in a sense,
looking at these different
narratives to address
these questions.
"What do you
do with blacks,
how are they going
to be controlled,
who will do the work, and
will the South survive the
upheaval?"
Now before
Lincoln is killed,
he starts trying very
aggressively to figure out
the best way to reunite
the country after the war.
He proposes a
ten percent plan.
It's called the
Ten Percent Plan.
And it is a--the elements
of the plan involve a
pardon to all Southerners,
except for Confederate
leaders, they
could not be excused.
A pardon would be given to
all Southerners who took
an oath of loyalty to
the Union and supported
emancipation.
Once ten percent of
a state population,
we're talking white males,
once ten percent of the
state population
agrees to this idea,
signs this loyalty oath,
a new government could be
formed.
Anti-slavery activists,
Congressional radicals,
people who are just
staunch supporters of the
Union efforts saying,
"This is way too lenient,
we have spilled too much
blood just to say if ten
percent of the South
goes along with this plan,
everything will
be forgiven."
The plan goes nowhere, and
Lincoln is assassinated.
Andrew Johnson takes
office and develops a plan
and a series of measures
that taken together are
captured in what we
call "Presidential
Reconstruction."
The basic terms
of Presidential
Reconstruction say that a
general pardon is given to
the white South, except
for Confederate leaders,
just like Lincoln's
plan, but Johnson's is
different.
He says, "We will
pardon everyone except for
Confederate leaders
and wealthy planters."
Johnson was a
man of the people,
coming from farming
roots, working very hard,
and saw that
moneyed land-owners,
plantation-owners, were a
real source of many of the
problems in the South.
So the pardon to
the white South,
except for Confederate
leaders and wealthy
planters, required
the end of slavery,
and then it would let
the South set up its own
governments.
And the thinking was
that the white yeoman
farmers--since
the white planters,
the wealthy planters,
would not be allowed to be
the leaders--that
white yeoman farmers,
people working sort of
hand-to-mouth and scraping
by, they would be the one
who would take control of
these governments and
restructure the society
more along sort
of, I would say,
agrarian class
sympathetic lines.
Plan moves forward, and
Johnson could not have
been more wrong
about what would happen.
He thought that there
would be a new egalitarian
ethos in the South, and
what happened is that once
the whites
take over office,
they begin to answer the
set of questions I posed
at the
beginning of the class,
in terms of what
to do with blacks,
with a rather
curious set of answers.
They enacted the
so-called "Black Codes."
I'm going to skip over
the Black Codes for the
moment, save that for the
social history part of the
lecture.
But they enact
the Black Codes.
The answer under Johnson
that the white governments
in the South provide does
not look a whole bunch
better than slavery for
many African Americans.
The
Republicans in Congress,
people who've been staunch
anti-slavery advocates,
are horrified at
Johnson's plan.
Lincoln's was
way too lenient,
Johnson's was stricter,
but it didn't change the
social order,
as it turns out.
And so Congress, the
Republicans in Congress,
they now
control the Congress,
sets about fighting
Johnson at every turn.
Johnson has a plan,
Congress overrules it.
Johnson vetoes
Congress's decision,
Congress beats
back the veto.
I mean, the government is
just locked in this battle
at the federal level on
all manner of issues.
During this period of
federal inside battling,
I suppose one
could call it,
Republican-controlled
Congress pushes through
the first Civil
Rights Act in 1866,
it pushes through the
Fourteenth Amendment
delineating the terms
of citizenship and due
process.
Due process is something
you'll be hearing--being
incredibly important for
freedom struggles as we
move forward
in this class.
And threatened--the
Congress threatens South's
representation in Congress
if blacks were denied the
right to vote.
Southern states, seeing
the handwriting on the
wall about the fact
that Republican-controlled
Congress, which is a
Northern Congress,
sees these terms and
just rejects them.
Congress gets tough and
ushers in a series of
reforms that become
known as "Radical
Reconstruction"
or "Congressional
Reconstruction," they
are the same thing.
Congressional
Reconstruction and Radical
Reconstruction.
Bless you.
So Johnson has a chance
to make a difference in
Reconstruction.
From 1865, with
Lincoln's assassination,
to 1867, that two
years of experimentation.
Congress says,
"Forget about it,
we're taking
control here,
--through sheer
numbers--and enters the
longest phase of
Reconstruction,
Congressional/Radical
from 1867 to 1877.
And it is a
radical change.
Under this new
Reconstruction plan,
the South is divided into
five military districts.
These districts are
controlled by Northern and
Republican governments.
There is quite literally a
military occupation of the
South by federal troops.
Congress pushes through
the Fifteenth Amendment in
1870, guaranteeing blacks,
and this is black males,
please understand,
guaranteeing them the
right to vote.
If you'd been a
slave, it doesn't matter.
If you're black,
it doesn't matter.
You have the
right to vote.
After this
amendment passes,
you start seeing a period
in the eras of different
Reconstructions, of
incredible positive change
for many African
Americans--not all,
but many.
And that change often
comes through--you can
mark it by the
dramatic increase (well,
increasing from zero to
anything is dramatic,
I suppose) but the
dramatic increase of
blacks holding office.
You start seeing black
men holding office at the
local level, being elected
to maybe a town council
let's say, in some places
being elected the local
sheriff, which is
really quite astonishing,
through state governments
and into the federal
government.
In Congress, and in the
House of Representatives,
and in the Senate.
The change in
representation,
that there are blacks in
government at all levels,
is astonishing
on many levels.
What is even
more astonishing,
I'll repeat this fact in
about ten weeks or eleven
weeks, is that the number
of black elected officials
in the federal government,
House of Representatives
and Senate,
blossoms during this era,
at the end of
Reconstruction,
which I'll start talking
about in the next lecture,
that those numbers
start to evaporate,
and the numbers do not
return as far as federal
representation of blacks
coming from the Southern
states, it does not return
until Bill Clinton is
elected President.
This is a radical change,
and it is so radical it
could not be
sustained, as we'll see.
But for the moment,
in 1870 through 1877,
at the level of politics,
electoral politics,
it seems there is a real
opportunity for change as
far as
representation--the local,
the state, the
federal level.
All of these
changes, federal
occupation--military
occupation of the South,
setting very aggressive
terms about how the
Southern governments could
be reformed and readmitted
to the Union, having
blacks hold elected
office, all of these
changes tear at the social
fabric of the South.
What I want to do for
the next bit is to start
looking at these changes
sort of on the ground.
Trying to help us
understand the ways in
which things had shifted
fundamentally for whites
and African Americans at
the moment of the end of
the Civil War.
Now as I alluded
earlier to the question,
"What are you going
to do with blacks?,
the central question of
the era is what one does
with blacks springs out
of the fact that freedom
meant different things
to different people.
Freedom meant
liberation for blacks,
and that part is
obvious certainly.
For whites, at that
moment of liberation,
those who had
slaves from small,
you know, small
slaveholding households,
two or three
slaves to plantations,
it means an
immediate loss of labor.
For blacks and whites it
means an immediate sense
of profound instability
in the social fabric.
In a very curious way, it
means for blacks in more
dangerous
situations--dangerous
moment.
Slaves' bodies...
It's all right. Okay.
Slaves' bodies had value,
literal value.
You were property.
If you did something--if
someone thinks you did
something wrong, black
person offends a white
person's sensibilities,
and a white person decides
to strike me, hit me,
hurt my body or something,
that white person has
damaged property that
belongs to somebody
else and they had to make
restitution.
After the end of
the Civil War,
black bodies were, from
a financial standpoint,
they had no value.
Now I remember actually
making this statement
during a public lecture at
a library during a series
of lectures in San Diego
and someone got very upset
with me: "Everybody
has value!" I mean yes,
everybody does have value,
but I'm talking of literal
dollars and cents.
Black bodies don't have
value after the moment,
the end of slavery, and
you can do what you want
to with them.
Freedom, you can't
discount it's important
for African Americans,
the moment of liberation.
But profound instability
you can't ignore either.
Now since the Southern
economy is devastated
after the war, during
the war and after the war,
since there's the loss of
labor that is profound,
white planters want a
quick return to plantation
labor, you got to get
crops in from the field.
And they understood
that we don't have slaves
anymore, but there's got
to be a way to get gang
labor reorganized,
have an overseer.
At the same time
black--white planters want
this, blacks who have
been working on these
plantations for example,
they've got to find a way
to put food on
their table,
but they want to
have economic autonomy,
be it land ownership.
They want to have
their own farms.
White farm-owners want
blacks to sign labor
contracts to commit
themselves to work on the
farms.
Blacks reject this saying
they expect the federal
government to
help them out.
They expect the federal
government to redistribute
land.
So you have these
really intense conflicting
expectations that are
directly related to
conflicting senses of
what freedom meant.
And if you look at some of
these items on the screen
here, I'll start
talking about them,
you'll start seeing where
these expectations come
from and why they
would be so conflicted and
complicated.
Now we're back in 1865.
Johnson is the president
and he wants to see the
Southern economy back on
track and wants blacks
back to work immediately.
The question is
how to do it.
He allows Southern
governments to reestablish
themselves
under Presidential
Reconstruction guidelines,
and once they do,
a lot of these
white governments start
answering the question
what to do with blacks and
establish Black Codes.
Now Black Codes were a
series of state-level laws
aimed at answering the
question what to do with
this newly
freed population.
There was one--there
wasn't a single set of
Black Codes, they
ranged broadly.
Some are more
strict than others,
but they are,
just taken together,
a series of legal concepts
that are seeking to create
a new labor system that
essentially put blacks
back to work.
Now you look at the codes,
you'll see they authorize
blacks to
acquire property,
something blacks
certainly wanted.
It authorized
blacks to marry,
something they were not
allowed to do when they
were slaves.
It authorized blacks
to make contracts,
sue and be sued, testify
in court against other
blacks, mind you.
All of these things are
essentially brand new,
so the Black
Codes on the surface,
at first glance, seemed to
be a way of trying to give
blacks some citizenship
rights they didn't have
before.
But look a
little more closely,
you'll also see many other
guidelines that make it
clear that the Black
Codes are about labor
stabilization.
Now I'm lumping all of
these things together
here.
Some state codes required
all blacks to have an
annual proof of
one-year labor contracts.
Basically you had
to sign up saying,
"I'm going to work
this plot of land at this
plantation, I'm going to
work in this shop for the
next year, and
I won't leave."
If you leave the job,
you sign that contract,
you leave the job
before the year is up,
you will lose all wages
that you had earned up to
that point.
And you might be subject
to arrest by a white
citizen.
And notice, I'm not
talking about the white
Chief of Police or Deputy,
you'd be arrested by a
white person walking
down the street who says,
"You know, you're not
working the way you should
be working.
You clearly should be
on that labor contract,
and what are
you doing here?"
Some Black Codes would say
that blacks couldn't steal
labor or else they risked
a five hundred dollar
fine, I mean a ridiculous
amount of money.
Now stealing labor, that
could be interpreted as
not working hard enough.
Or that could be
interpreted as when you're
working this plot of land,
saving a little bit of
that part for yourself.
Not maximizing the
return on the investment,
essentially, that white
property-owners had made.
If you steal labor
you could be fined five
hundred dollars.
In other states blacks
were forbidden to rent
land in urban areas.
The notion was if you have
them closer to a city,
you might have critical
masses developing of
African Americans who
are property owners,
or at least renters.
They might be able to
develop their own economic
opportunities
through informal networks,
essentially allowing
blacks to rent property in
towns gave them
too much autonomy,
the fear was.
Black Codes forced
black women back on farms.
This way they would not
be seen in public spaces.
This was all for the
good of the woman,
this is for
the black women,
they should really be in
their natural habitat.
This would've been the
language of the day,
by the way.
Black Codes
regulated sexual behavior.
You could not
dress a certain way,
you could not be out
at a certain hour.
Black Codes would
address vagrancy,
idleness, rude
gestures, mischief,
preaching the Gospel
without a license and so
on.
I mean, incredibly vague.
If you're just
kind of hanging out,
you could be in
violation of a Black Code.
If you're up to no
good, being mischievous,
violation of a Black Code.
And all of these
could lead to fines or
involuntary
plantation labor.
Black Codes forced
apprenticeships on black
minors--black
young people,
not miners, minors.
They would have to
work without wages.
It's mainly orphans or
children of poor parents.
Many of the Black
Codes said that they
could--blacks could
not hunt or own weapons.
This is a very
important limitation,
because in the
rural South,
you shot your food.
But the idea was, "If we
start giving blacks guns,
they may not shoot
food, they may shoot us."
So blacks can't
hunt or own weapons.
So you take all
these things together,
and again, I've lumped
many different state's
Black Codes here, it's
clear that while everyone
wants the Southern
economy back on track,
I mean everybody does,
there's no rational way of
justifying doing it
via the Black Codes.
And so fairly soon after
their being established,
sometimes in
less than a year,
these Black Codes are
declared illegal and are
eliminated.
So we're talking about a
very--a brief moment in
time.
This sort of underscores
the notion of we're at a
period of improvisation
and experimentation,
"We'll try this until
we're told it doesn't work
any longer."
In the place of
the Black Codes,
a new labor
system develops.
This one was much
more focused--much more
explicitly focused upon
labor instead of all the
morality issues that you
see in the Black Codes.
And this new labor system,
that becomes incredibly
successful for
what it was,
is called sharecropping.
Sharecropping
revolves around credit.
The whites own the
land, the tools,
the seed, but they
didn't own the labor.
That's what
blacks controlled.
So blacks could
use the land,
the tools, and the seed,
but they did not get paid
in cash.
Instead they would rent
the white's property and
their tools, etcetera.
And in order to
get the seed,
they'd have to go to the
company store for their
purchases.
And the store would be
sort of like Durfee's,
you know,
exorbitantly priced.
So, you know, if a bag of
seed on the market--I'm
making up the
numbers here,
might have
cost one dollar,
at the company
store maybe it's three,
three credits,
three units,
or something like that.
So sharecroppers
would pay for their food,
their seed, etcetera
with their shares,
their portions of the crop
that they were growing and
later harvesting
for the landowner.
At the end of the year
when the crop in question,
let's just say
it's cotton,
which it would've been for
a tremendous amount of the
system, when the
cotton is taken to market,
the cotton that black
sharecroppers had planted
and harvested, they
would not be able to go to
market with
the cotton crop.
The landowner
would go there,
or his business manager,
and he'd sell the cotton
at the market rate.
Then he would come back
and make a declaration of
how much he was
able to get for this,
settle the accounts
privately with the
landowner, and the
landowner and labor then
settled their accounts.
And then a funny
thing happened.
Almost inevitably, at
the end of the year,
after the planting cycle,
when the crop came--was
sent to market--and they
came back with the money
for it, they
looked at the balances,
and blacks owed money
to the sharecropper,
Every year.
Let's just say,
again making up numbers,
that if I'm a sharecropper
and I spent a thousand
dollars at the company
store to buy all the--rent
the equipment or buy the
seeds or whatnot for my
plot of land, I get
this amazing crop,
it goes off to
market, come back,
and the guy said
"You know what?
I was only able to get
nine hundred dollars."
I now owe a hundred
dollars to the landowner.
What this meant
was I'm stuck,
because it is illegal to
skip out on your debts.
So the sharecroppers are
required to go back to
work for the same person
in an attempt to eliminate
the debt.
So you have another--and
the cycle just keeps
repeating itself, you
never get out of debt,
you're always
working the land.
What this meant
is that, you know,
maybe you aren't being
whipped by an overseer,
but you are in
perpetual servitude,
as far as your labor
and debt is concerned,
to the landowner.
You can't escape it.
Sharecropping
works like a charm.
It really begins in
earnest in the mid-1860s
or the later 1860s, it is
still popular in the South
through the 1940s.
Only with systematic
mechanization of farms
do you have sharecroppers
being relieved of that
particular economic cycle.
So white attempts to
answer the question of
what one could do to
get blacks back to work,
revolved around
various attempts,
whether it's through
the Black Codes or the
sharecropping system, they
revolved around various
attempts to get--to
recreate slavery,
but with a different name
and a slightly different
nature.
As I mentioned
before, black--I mean,
thinking about
freedom from the black's
perspective also
meant labor instability.
This is why the Black
Codes are so draconian,
this is why there's
such emphasis on you can't
escape debt.
This was a way to
control blacks.
Now remember,
blacks had expectations,
too, after the
Civil War was over.
They wanted their freedom,
they got their freedom in
the literal sense, there's
no doubt about that.
But there were also
expectations about land
ownership, that they would
have land they could work
themselves, and there were
expectations the federal
government would be the
entity to help blacks
navigate their arrival to
full citizenship rights
and property ownership.
And these expectations
grow out of the Bureau of
Refugees, Freedmen
and Abandoned Lands,
and out of Field Order 15.
The Bureau is established,
The Field Order's
enunciated,
Black Codes enacted,
all at the same moment,
so these are overlapping
narratives.
Expectations about
land, access to it,
grows from Union General
Sherman's seemingly
apocalyptic
March to the Sea,
in which he burned his
way through and across the
South, and while doing so
issued the famous Field
Order 15, which declared
that in part--declared in
part that coastal
land between Charleston,
South Carolina,
and Jacksonville,
Florida, was from this
point on for blacks.
If Congress had
accepted this promise,
or acted upon
this promise,
excuse me, it would've
given over land to roughly
about two hundred thousand
African Americans.
The Field Order,
declared in 1865,
doesn't redistribute
land, but there is the
expectation that the
government is going to do
so through the likes
of violence perhaps,
with General Sherman, or
through an orderly attempt
at giving assistance, and
that's through the Bureau
of Freed Refugees,
Freedmen and Abandoned
Lands, more often known
as the Freedmen's Bureau.
The Freedmen's Bureau
was established in March,
1865.
It takes a while to get
itself up and running.
It's organized under the
General--Union General
Otis O.
Howard--that's why Howard
University's named after
this man, he gave his
land to the university.
The Freedmen's Bureau
had the task of providing
food, shelter, and medical
aid for the destitute.
That's blacks as
well as whites.
It had the duty of
providing education for
freed people.
To say that there was an
educational system for
blacks is ludicrous up
to this moment in time.
It's also kind of
ludicrous after the fact,
but they were
working on it.
The Freedmen's Bureau
establishes free labor
arrangements in
former plantation areas.
Essentially it's charged
with trying to help blacks
develop an economic system
where they could sign to
do work and contract, but
they had freedom in doing
so.
And the Freedmen's Bureau
is charged with securing
justice for blacks
in legal proceedings.
The Freedmen's Bureau
record on this front is
mixed at best.
You know from Field Order
15 that it's the potential
of returning or giving
all this land to blacks
doesn't really happen.
Freedmen's Bureau,
they're talking about,
you know, famous
"Forty Acres and a Mule"
ideology.
The Freedmen's
Bureau is in control of,
at one point, eight
hundred and fifty thousand
acres of property,
that instead of being
transferred to poor
whites and to blacks,
is transferred back to the
original property owners.
So these white planters
lost their land in the
war, and after
some sorting out,
they got their
land right back.
The notion of establishing
wage labor contracts,
that blacks are not going
to be working for a year
like in the sharecropping
system that would've
developed, but they
would be paid wages,
doesn't work.
So the Freedmen's Bureau
doesn't distribute land
like it promised it would,
fails in establishing wage
labor contracts.
But it does do something
really remarkable in that
it starts
establishing schools.
Now again, these schools
would not be on par with
white schools,
not by a long shot.
But again, when
you start from zero,
any change is a
radical change.
So from 1865, the
moment it was founded,
to 1869, three thousand
new schools for blacks,
these are
shacks essentially,
are established.
So the Freedmen's Bureau
seems to at least on one
level be doing
something right,
making a real change.
But by 1872,
it's gone as well.
It collapses.
So it leaves us
with a mixed record.
The record of
Radical Reconstruction,
in fact, for much of
the 1870s is mixed.
The North is growing
increasingly weary of
Southern intransigents,
incredible resistance to
these kinds of changes.
Southerners are tired of
the Northern presence and
were angry at having
new state constitutions
written under
Republican-controlled
governments that, as far
as white Southerners were
concerned, gave away way
too much in terms of the
rights and
citizenships to black men.
This period of
sorting out,
of radical changes at the
electoral level that are
highly positive for
African Americans,
there's no debating that,
that are of mixed success
on the ground for the
great majority of African
Americans--but clearly
it's better to be free
than slave, despite
all the dangers that are
incumbent with it.
It is a period of
incredible stress,
and resentment, and of
different ways in which
whites try to
assert control.
"What are we going to
do with these blacks?
Who's going to
control them?"
One of the first answers
was the establishment of
the KKK, the Ku Klux Klan,
established in Tennessee
in 1866.
You didn't need the Klan
prior to emancipation,
but as far as many
whites were concerned,
you needed something
like the Klan after.
Klan members would go
after white Northerners
who were holding
elected office,
would threaten them
with assassination and
assassinate some of
them, would go after,
you know, Jews
and Catholics,
and certainly went
after blacks as well.
Klan forms in 1866, but
remember this is a period
of military presence from
the North and the South,
and under General Grant,
the Klan is wiped out
within two years.
For a while.
But even though the
Klan is wiped out,
you can see
through this era,
1865 to 1877, rising
tides of resentment,
chaffing by
white Southerners,
rising tides of--I
guess one might just say
impatience by black
Americans in "When are we
going to have
real change?"
And real change did come,
but not in the way that
African
Americans had hoped.
In 1876, it's the
presidential election,
the two men left standing
are Samuel Tilden,
the Democrat,
and Rutherford B.
Hayes, Republican.
Tilden wins the
popular vote,
but not-- the electoral
vote was unclear because
the results from the
Southern states were so
contested.
Sounds like recent
history in fact.
A compromise
though is reached,
that Hayes,
the Republican,
would secure
the Presidency,
but only if he promised
to withdraw federal troops
from the North--excuse me,
from the South--end the
military occupation, let
the Southern states all
come back into the Union.
Hayes accepts the
deal--the North again was
exhausted by
all the struggle.
And with this famous
compromise of 1877,
Reconstruction ends.
Now with the end
of Reconstruction,
we get a new period of
American life generally
referred to as
"Redemption."
When the white
South shall rise again,
they will
redeem themselves.
And I'll be talking about
Redemption in the next
lecture.
But I want to turn now
from a moment of high
politics--or discussion
of high politics and a
discussion of
social history,
sort of life
on the ground,
to take a moment to
look at some other types
of--some primary sources
that helps us understand
what I'll just call the
political culture of the
moment.
Very famous image,
"What miscegenation is.
What we are to expect
now that Mr. Lincoln is
reelected."
Talking 1864 now.
I mentioned in
the first lecture,
you know, nation states
declaring their cultures,
and the ideologies,
and their myths on their
currency.
Well, you can see it as
well in political posters,
certainly
political cartoons.
And this is a--represents
a kind of theme we're
going to see a fair
amount in this course.
Just like the currency of
exalted white womanhood.
And in this
case, a caricature,
a very dark-skinned
caricature of an African
American man.
Caricature as
being of black males,
as you probably already
know and will certainly
know more, very alive and
well during this period
and certainly even to
today in different ways,
something we'll talk about
later on in the course.
But a broadside talking
about "This is what we're
going to expect now that
Lincoln's been reelected.
All hope's been lost.
White women and black men
will connect in this sort
of way."
Now this one I think is
interesting 'cause often
the notion is that black
men are assaulting white
women, but in this
case, you have--her arm is
wrapped around, not
in seeming protest.
Be that as it may, the
notion of black and white
mingling in this sort of
way was a profound threat.
This is 1864.
Now I talked about the
Freedmen's Bureau and the
work that it was
assigned to do.
It's there to establish
wage labor contracts,
and try to help navigate
land redistribution,
it seemed at first, and
try to help provide basic
assistance and education
to African Americans.
Well, on the political
campaigns in 1866,
after the
Freedmen's Bureau has been
established,
you start seeing
representations--again
another very famous
poster--representations
of what Reconstruction
actually means, the
Freedmen's Bureau,
or what--excuse me, the
Freedmen's Bureau means.
"The Freedmen's Bureau, an
agency to keep the Negro
in idleness at the
expense of the white man,
twice vetoed by the
President and made a law
by Congress.
Support Congress and
you support the Negro.
Sustain the President
and you protect the white
man."
Another caricature of
an African American in
tatters, 'cause he doesn't
really need to be dressed;
he doesn't really
care, barefoot,
idle, happy as can be.
The white man looking
on, working very hard,
trying to earn his
keep, do the right thing.
Now, aside from this being
a very famous poster,
sort of capturing the
sentiment or resentment
about the Freedmen's
Bureau being there to
assist the lazy
African American,
this is also important
to highlight the ways in
which these narratives
appear in surprising
places and
ways, or at least,
ways that we today might
think are surprising.
This is a campaign
ad, not in Alabama,
not in Mississippi,
but in Pennsylvania.
It's an ad regarding an
election in 1866 pitting
John Geary, Republican,
against Hiester Clymer for
the governorship
of Pennsylvania.
Clymer's
saying, the Democrat,
is saying, "If
you support Geary,
you're supporting this.
Black idleness."
From the same
campaign--and this is
dramatic I think,
pretty dramatic as well,
but you see the notion of
caricature and ideals of
white beauty but in a
different sort of way in
the same campaign,
another broadside.
Pretty direct here.
Clymer's platform is
for the white man.
Geary's platform
is for the negro.
Read the platforms.
Again, if you're
supporting Geary,
represented here by the
grotesque representation
of a black male, if
you're representing Geary,
you're representing all
of those things that are
wrong about
excess, idleness,
illiteracy,
sexual aggression,
all of these things that
are associated with black
male,
especially in this case,
black male behavior.
If you support Clymer,
you support someone who's
educated, who's refined,
who's disciplined.
So we go from this
image, which is sort of a
grotesquery, very busy,
lots of different texts
and representations, to
this one that's cleaner as
it were, more upfront
about its representations,
to in
1868--these are typical,
these are not exceptional
advertisements--in 1868 in
the Presidential,
Democratic Presidential
Primary, New York Governor
Horatio Seymour who was
the Governor of the state
during the New York City
draft riots and who
did not pursue the draft
rioters, the Irish who
burned parts of the city
and attacked and killed
people and attacked the
military, he
didn't punish them,
which--and he's a
Republican now,
and people thought that he
was a traitor to the Union
army---or to the
Union--in support of the
Confederacy.
Anyway, New York Governor
Horatio Seymour is running
with Francis Blair
from Missouri for the
Democratic nomination.
And they announce
their ticket...
couldn't be more simple.
Our motto, "This is a
white man's country,
let white men rule."
So you see a range of
images here that have been
popularly distributed.
Pennsylvania
race for Governor,
presidential primary,
again a northern governor,
in this case represented
on the presidential part
of the ticket.
A language, a
visual language,
and sometimes
just flat-out words,
of course, making it
clear that this era of
transition is
not an easy one,
that there's intransigence
in all different corners
and all different
regions from different
perspectives.
And if you're thinking I'm
over-reading these things,
let me just show this last
image that sends a message
to Northerners who are
coming down to save the
South, take
over the South,
occupy the
South--carpetbaggers,
people who would load up
their things in a bag from
the North, come down to
the South and set up a
government, set up
a business and take
advantage of
Southern resources,
certainly a
lot of them did.
The South had an
answer for these people,
and you would
see posters up on,
you know, plastered onto a
tree or a wall that would
simply say this.
This is the nature of
this visual conversation,
if you will, of
this moment in time;
a period of
tremendous sorting out,
a period it seems of
incredible possibility and
hope, as far as the
elected realm is concerned
for African Americans,
a period much more
complicated on the ground
for African Americans and
for poor whites certainly,
a period of growing or
sustaining intransigence
by white elected officials
in the South, and a
period where white elected
officials in the North
aren't quite certain about
this whole period, this
whole idea of trying to
reconstruct the
Union along these terms.
The answers that I posed
at the beginning of the
class were answered--the
questions I posed at the
beginning of the class
were answered through
these narratives.
And we'll see some more
answers when we resume
class the next session
and talk about Redemption.
Thank you.